let's get more on our top story this
evening in the U.S Coast Guard has
expanded the search area in the hunt for
the submersible that went missing near
the wreck of the Titanic on Sunday five
people are on board that tourist vessel
including a British billionaire and a
uk-based Pakistani businessman and his
son Ocean Gate Expeditions whose founder
is also on board says the vessel carries
96 hours of oxygen supplies well I'm
joined Now by Roger mallinson who was
rescued when his submersible sank off
the coast of Ireland way back in 1973
and 50 years on that incident Remains
the deepest sub rescue in history and
Roger is with me now and Roger well
first of all you'd been working off the
Atlantic coast of Ireland in that mini
sub 1500 feet I'm told below the surface
laying a phone cable tell me what
happened when it all go went wrong how
did it all go wrong
well it's it went wrong after the
the
which we we've got Pisces three from
high court from the makers in in
Vancouver and they bro we we got it as
Vickers as a wreck and we rebuilt it we
took the sphere to Pieces x-rayed every
every bit of it and
x-rayed the cracks in the in the welding
and re-welded it and re-machined it and
rebuild the whole sub rebuild the frames
and then redid All the pipe work
Hydraulics oxygen
compressed air
oil and
we did all the electrics and the Motors
and the batteries
and the batteries are in plastic boxes
out in the sea and when we finished it
it went out to Vickers absolutely as new
and we took it out into the in the sound
of Russia and did some pre pre-tests and
then took it out in the Atlantic and we
worked all summer in the Atlantic in
very deep water and very rough water and
really tested it we did by the end of
the year we're doing over 200 hour 200
and
the 20 odd
um Dives and we'd never had a fault on
it I was very proud of it it was lots of
it was my work but there was other folks
that I worked with they had did work on
it and I was very pleased with it and
then
right at the end of the year we'd had no
weekends we'd had no holidays we'd had
absolutely nothing and they wanted to
sub in the North Sea
for the New Orleans
platforms that they were starting in the
North Sea and so they decided to move
base so instead of the best being in
Barrow
which we'd never been back to since we
met it uh
they wanted it in Leaf near Edinburgh
right and so
I'm sorry Roger told me that Roger just
tell me the moment
um because we haven't got that long but
tell me the moment so it went wrong did
it when you came to the surface because
you did your job as far as I can can see
but when it came to the surface there
was a there was it a crack in the in the
compartment
no there was nothing wrong with this
soap it was suddenly when we got back
into Leith there was a problem with a
change of of crew member person in
charge and when we got back into into
Leaf we found every dive that they've
been diving I went on holiday for three
weeks and when I came back
after three weeks holiday there was
every dive that they've been diving in
the North Sea which was only in 200 feet
when we've been diving to five eight
thousand feet in the Atlantic and every
day there was watering grass in their
sphere so why was the water Ingress
enough sphere and you saw this fella
that was in charge and you just could
not talk to him it was every time he
spoke to him he was over rolled over the
officer graduation engineer right and
and that's his attitude and you just
could not get on with them at all but
how did you how was that doing something
to the hutch yeah so that you're going
to tell me how was it that you went to
the you sank to the bottom of the the
sea to the seabed how did that happen
well this was
we we have sorted he'd he'd taken his
hats to pieces and made a total mess of
it but wouldn't admit it and wouldn't
tell us what he'd done and it took us
quite a lot of weeks it took a locking
bar off which was promised back in
42 days we'd asked on the day we went
out to Cork and when we got to Cork we
still had no locking bar and you
couldn't hold the hatch on without it
and we were diving in 100 foot 100 mile
an hour winds and and 90-foot seas
without anything holding the hatch on
and it was absolutely disgrace but we
were still expected to dive it and so as
we joined the sub I asked oh by the way
lockingbird come back yet and I got a
face full of swear words which I
wouldn't dare say what I got now for
asking and it disappointed me or
disgusted me that much that I did
something about it and three years later
I was working on the sub doing some
repairs that other folk had left while I
was on holiday and they
um
we got out to the side
and I was getting a subreddy late at
night 11 o'clock at night and we're
diving it
um one o'clock in the morning to start
the the dive out on on this uh
come to telephone cable and
everything as far as I know was all
right then
would stop the leak in their sphere
because
he'd broken some cut some more rings by
bad work and really replaced the O-rings
and that was sorted
but uh
no
we
we started our dive and we went down to
1675 feet and we
we did
a really good day's work
and it was it was all new wood new type
work would not done any of this sort of
stuff before Roger Roger that was just
sorry to interact Roger we're running
out of time I just want you to tell us
when you were trapped down there what
was it like what was it what was it like
down there with you were down there with
your colleague
okay well the hutch no we got we got on
the job we finished it we finished that
day's work and we came up at the end of
the day well it was the end of the night
we were coming up early in the morning
for breakfast and a good night's sleep
and we got
up on the surface and
the uh
we heard the diver get on
and the diver was to put the Tour line
on to tour us back onto the back of the
Mothership
and
suddenly the back of the silver dipped
down and then we got water alarm
screaming
and
we were totally flooded
they diver instead of the divers
connecting the tall line to the hatch to
the sub
at the bottom of this of the
of the atmosphere he connected it to the
hatch and pulled the hutch off
and
and would never admit it afterwards but
that's what happened he pulled the hatch
off and then
we took two and a half ton of water on
and went down under the ship it
connected the tall line on incorrectly
but it connected it on and we were
fussing through a six foot strop which
was only five ton breaking strain
now remember with 90-foot seeds going
and so by the time we went down onto the
end of the Tour line we were two and a
half ton heavy at the stern and
suddenly they they
tall line went tight and the back of the
sub was pulled upwards and we were
facing down now and then the ship
dropped and we would we fell down at the
back and it went like this for three
minutes well it wasn't going to last
very long before the Rope would break
and it suddenly went off like a cannon
going off and the hatch
flew back across onto the ship
and
it must have been frightening because it
was still attached
so very frightening and we crushed to
the seabed in in 26 seconds where we'd
taken
for
four minutes to come up
and it suddenly went down in 26 seconds
and it's how were you rescued ridiculous
how were you rescued and how long did it
take they were Rescue It took 84 hours
to rescue us we were we were stuck on
the bottom with oh totally flooded in
the upstairs not where we were but in
the atmosphere we had a little battery
power left because we'd use that much
working on the job we were doing
and luckily before we started the dive
I stole a bottle of oxygen and because
we'd stole it it I'm still here
otherwise we certainly wouldn't have
been here good grief well let me run out
just just after we crashed on the bottom
we were to run out
did you think you weren't going to make
it at one point because 80 hours is a
long time certainly did
84 hours is a very long time and it's we
didn't have enough food we didn't have
enough oxygen we didn't have enough
um
the battery power to run the scrubber
and we just had to really be rationing
everything
and look after each other and I think we
looked after each other and I think that
that
was a major
major lifesaver
well that was a 1500 feet Roger how what
do you think of what's happened now in
the Atlantic that's 12 000 feet
um four thousand meters what do you
think of what's Happening
that is horrendous I I can't understand
why they haven't
who haven't transmitted some some signal
of some sort
um I have a horrible feeling that
something might be seriously wrong that
they aren't able to sit transmit a
signal but I would have thought a hammer
on this on a bit of the hole somewhere
would would be a good transmitter
then it would be wood Curry
well listen Roger we um we thank you for
telling your story it's an extraordinary
story and um thank you very much for
coming on our program and we obviously
hope that uh some sort of rescue can
happen in this one day I might build
might one day I might be able to see it
well that's that would be something but
listen thank you very much indeed Roger
for coming on
yeah
thank you thank you welcome thank you
very much